how are you good to see you good to see
you carlos
so ajac is the leader here you know the
eternals look to her for guidance is
that the role you also took on set as
well
oh i don't know not necessarily but i
did get along very very well with
everyone and i did make a couple of
reunions for everyone
and i did make a christmas party
um
that was what a good leader does
yes yes yes
i've been loving the stories about you
and angelina hanging out the birthday
party you guys seem like good homies is
that was that the vibe is that what was
it like the two of you hanging out
together making events
you know i didn't i had no idea
i was gonna love her so much i had no
idea you know if i was gonna love her
uh i kind of did i already
super respected her work
but she's a surprise to me she's so easy
going
i mean
the interesting thing is that we
finished these two years ago
and we had the carbon and everything and
we we stayed in touch and it's been like
really organic
and just easy
and where love
i knew i was gonna love her when i saw
what a good mother she is and so we can
relate to each other
mamas always like to like
stick together that's the thing that's
the thing about mothers and help each
other out and uh but
she's just uh amazing and fun
yes you know
one thing that i really appreciate about
this movie is
you know we talk about diversity and
especially the mcu we're really seeing
it now with eternals but it's also like
a broader scope of the human experience
with what tina is going through with
what they're all going through what is
it like for you was it mean to represent
this
on such a broad scale
i loved carlos
a lot it's almost like a dream come true
it's almost like
you know when you say i mean i don't
want to exaggerate but just to give you
like an example
oh you know i wish for world peace
oh i wish for hollywood
to cast the the
super action movies with people that
look completely different and are
different ages and even sex orientations
and
you know there are just unique in
different ways that it's okay if you're
deaf because it is okay or if you
struggle with some kind of mental
illness and
not one thing defines everything that
you are
and
um
to to create a family where we don't
even
talk about it we're just there for each
other or
um
and we see
further than
the things that sometimes stigmatize you
in life
and you know i'm
a middle-aged woman that it's
latino and arab
and i am playing i am playing a
superhero
that is a man in the comics
and now it's a woman
so it's just like one of those things
that
you wish
that it could happen one day but that
you are really doubtful that it would
happen one day but it did
and here we are and it's awesome
it is
well thank you so much for your time it
was a pleasure speaking with you
congratulations